v rising is a survival crafting game
that puts players in the shoes of a
vampire who's looking to rebuild a lost
empire here are seven beginners tips to
navigate the early game of v rising
chances are your first death in v rising
came at the hands of the giant fireball
in the sky
yes just like all pieces of vampire
fiction the sun plays a major role in
this game given the fact that you're a
bloodsucker a vampire's main weakness is
sunlight and this remains true in v
rising essentially you want to stay in
the shade as much as possible even if
this means getting under a tree you need
to stay under any form of shade during
the daytime hours however the sun moves
with the clock as the day goes on so
your shady spot won't always be safe to
combat this issue mainly in your base
you can construct a missed brazier when
filled with bones this structure emits a
mist that stops all sunlight from
penetrating through to a certain area
filling your base with these will ensure
that you can continue to work in your
base throughout the day if you want to
go out into the wilderness then stick to
the trees
one of the earliest tasks you have to
complete in v rising is crafting
different kinds of gear from armor to
weapons this gear will allow you to
gather resources and fight enemies more
efficiently speaking of efficiency you
want to learn the different traits each
piece of your gear possesses for example
if you look at the axis traits you'll
see that it has a 25 bonus damage to
lumber basically this means you want to
use your axe to chop down any trees the
same goes for the mace and stone the
sword and vegetation and the spear for
combat the spear is arguably one of the
most important items to craft in the
early game v-rising doesn't have a
specific mission for it early on leading
players to believe the sword is the best
weapon for fighting enemies however the
spear has 25 bonus damage against
enemies making it the best choice for
combat you can craft it at a workbench
using copper ingots
an underappreciated aspect of v rising
is your blood type and your overall
blood level at the bottom of your screen
right in the center there is a sphere
with blood in it this determines what
your current blood level is and you want
to keep the level as high as possible to
ensure you don't start withering away
and lose health you can consume rats and
feed on enemies if they're at a low
enough hp to restore your blood levels
feeding on enemies can also change your
blood type you can see which blood type
you currently are by hovering over the
sphere of blood on your screen
depending on the enemy you feed on you
can alter your blood type all of which
offer different bonuses for various
situations for example if you feed on a
worker type enemy your blood type will
change and increase the amount you
gather and mine out in the world to feed
on an enemy get them to a low portion of
their hp and then hit e when the game
prompts you to feed you don't want to do
this with other enemies around as you're
vulnerable and can be hit during this
process although you can also interrupt
it if you wish feeding on an enemy kills
them so it serves two purposes
once your base is up and running with
the castle heart you can begin to craft
different stations one of these stations
is called the blood altar which is a
vital addition to your base the blood
altar is essentially the rising's boss
tracker by interacting with it you can
see all of the available bosses in the
area you're currently in these bosses
are able to be tracked provided you meet
the level requirement to take on the
boss after you start tracking them you
will see a blood trail start forming in
the air this blood trail points in the
direction that you need to go to find
the boss you're tracking while it's a
bit finicky at times following the blood
trail is usually straightforward follow
the direction it's facing and with
enough luck you'll stumble across the
boss as you defeat more and more bosses
more content will be unlocked for you
back at your base and also the boss
you've defeated will unlock different
abilities and skills for you to use
unlike other survival crafting games
such as valheim the map in v rising
isn't procedurally generated instead
there are set locations for all points
of interest bosses and other places in
the game if you open the map there will
be different yellow circles marking
exactly where you can find various
points of interest you'll need to
explore the map in order for it to
become clear and present the points of
interest markers will also pop up as you
discover different locations like caves
and teleporters but one of the best
features of the map is that you can see
which resources are available in the
different areas of the rising's world
hover over the points of interest to see
what might be located there if you
decide to venture out of course some
resources like leather or a whetstone
might still be difficult to come across
even with all this information but
luckily for you i'm gonna tell you
exactly how to find and craft wet stones
and leather easiest and perhaps earliest
location you can find wet stones at is
bandit strongholds these are points of
interest on the map which are marked by
the yellow circles i mentioned earlier
now not every point of interest will be
a bandit stronghold but there are a
couple in the starting region of farbane
woods once you find one clear out the
bandits that are there and loot their
bodies these bandits occasionally drop
whetstones so make sure to take as many
of them out as possible in the location
itself there will be several lootable
items scattered across the ground and
other parts of the stronghold or camp
there will usually be a few whetstones
able to be picked up though some
locations might hold more or less of the
resource after some time in v rising you
will gain the ability to craft your own
whetstones the crafting recipe is tied
to the boss grayson the armorer who has
a level requirement of 27. now the first
step to adding some leather to your
inventory is to craft the tannery
station within your base but before you
do that during the early portion of
v-rising you'll stumble across wolves
bears and other animals now when you
kill these animals they will drop animal
hide you'll want to store as much of
this animal hide inside of a chest at
your base because it will be vital later
in order to gain access to the tannery
you will need to kill keely the frost
archer once that's done the tannery is
found under the refinement tab of the
build menu and requires eight planks and
160 animal hide to craft now you can
start making your own leather you have
the ability to craft new pieces of gear
and additional base items if the sun
doesn't kill you then v-rising's enemies
will surely force you to respawn once or
twice there seems to be a chance for any
leveled enemy to spawn anywhere on the
map and this can present a huge
challenge for you if you don't
understand how enemy levels work if an
enemy has an orange or red health bar
then they are considered a higher level
than you while you can probably still
fight and kill these enemies it will be
difficult and consume quite a bit of
your hp
if you run into an enemy with a skull by
their name they're considered a much
higher level than you and you should
probably tuck your tail and run one
common enemy with a skull by their name
that you'll likely come across in
farbane woods is the stone golem if
you're unlucky enough to see them your
only choice is to run fast and far so
they have it our beginners tips for the
rising for more videos like this one
make sure to subscribe to gamespot on
youtube and check out our written guides
over on gamespot.com you can find me on
twitter i'm lucy james games and we'll
catch you next time
[Music]